I want to do kind of a head and heart
check of this moment of time wherein how
are you doing how are you feeling about
the state of the world and the movement
that's happening outside our doors as
you know I've always been very vocal
about justice for african-american men
in particular it's just really always at
the forefront of talking about race
relations and so this is nothing new to
me
but it's very exciting to see the whole
world participating in this whole
movement because it's just not the
United States you know I see them
protesting in Paris London the Middle
East and so that's refreshing I'm
hopeful that positive things will come
from this what I think is very different
about this moment in time is because we
have such a divisive leader that it
basically has propelled this movement
because when you've got a leader who's
leading like our president is leading it
allows for this type of energy and so
wow you know some might see it as a very
bad thing like I'm telling people you
know just like we saw you know the whole
movement for women you know sexual
harassment you know I think this is the
about time movement it's about time we
have this very hard discussion because
there's a very sorted pass with race
relations throughout the world not just
the United States but throughout the
world but in particularly in this
country yesterday actually directed race
art
Brooks's funeral so that was a very
heavy moment but I was you know happy to
serve the family happy to have moments
with this you know it's beautiful wife
their beautiful children and you know
just to be present
[Music]
following the funeral his wife Tamika
Miller she requested that we take her by
the Wendy's where the incident occurred
and I rode with her in the car and we
had such a very point conversation about
this moment in time because she said to
me I never knew that I would be in this
place you know and I turn turn I said
but this place is a place of purpose a
place of power because you're now the
face of a entirely new movement within
the movement and so you know she said he
had always talked about being you know
well known and doing things that would
change the world and I told I said you
know sometimes we don't reach true
fruition until you know unfortunately
until we have left the world and I mean
we see that so many people in death
there is greatness sometimes and so you
know no one wants to die but it in depth
there sometimes becomes the start of a
movement and so you know George Floyd
started the movement rashard added
another effort to the flame
to make it even bigger and you know we
grow through that Wendy's it was
unbelievable how many people were out
there still with their hands up you know
saying you know black lives matter with
you you know we took the casket and you
know the flower cart and the entire
family around the drive-through you know
the same place where you know the fatal
shots were fired and so to be there with
his beautiful you know these young
children our one-year-old daughter
two-year-old daughter eight-year-old
daughter his son mother law in the same
car into you know just feel the power
the energy of them being able to release
the hurt that they had from that tragic
incident it was
moving to me as a person of color but as
a mother you know it just gave me a
whole new sense of purpose because we
have to propel this movement we have to
have this conversation we have to change
policy procedures laws we have to make
sure that there is equality for everyone
and so it was it was a beautiful
ceremony so many people came out I've
never seen a funeral ceremony and I've
been in this business now for about 13
years you know and so I've never seen a
ceremony a funeral home going as we call
in our culture where there were there
were more black men at this funeral than
I've ever seen in my life I mean it it
was unbelievable how much support from
the community and you know just
celebrities that came out and so to see
everyone come together unified in our
city which is a you know this is the
movement the mecca of the civil rights
movement it was it was beautiful and so
I'm just happy that I was able to serve
the family and to be of service you know
at that moment you are raising two black
sons what kind of conversations are you
having with them in this moment and this
is what's difficult I think because it
was such a harsh experience for our
grandparents and our parents from my
generation I think they tried to shield
us with it because they didn't want us
to know the pain that came with telling
the true story of what it felt like to
be discriminate against my mother
integrated her I think her middle school
or high school and so you know she
speaks about it but growing up it wasn't
as if I knew all the horrors of racism
because you know we lived in the
middle-class community my parents
weren't you know schoolteachers pastors
and so you know I grew up you know in a
very nice environment I've always you
know lived amongst people who are very
diverse
you know growing up I was always taught
you know when you go out the store you
get a receipt in the bag because you
don't want anyone's accused you of
stealing you know don't put your hands
in your pockets because you don't want
anyone to think you're doing something
that could lead you know you getting in
trouble I was always taught to say you
know yes sir no sir to anybody in a
position of authority but I think as
we've elevated to levels you know of
wealth you know and you start to really
become very integrated into a different
socioeconomic status you really stop
telling those very difficult stories to
your children and so now you know my
children obviously saw the George Floyd
incident on television could not
understand why that was happening and so
my youngest son was very much so and you
know why why did he you know put his you
know what did he do why did that happen
and so we had a really harsh discussion
about it and I had to tell them the
truth but we had also had the discussion
with the whole carpet chance incident
came about you know in the spring and my
son said well why don't we eat Papa
John's anymore and I said because as a
consumer
we will not patronize people who speak
in a certain way about different
cultures and so you know I explained to
him you know historically what that
means you know to use the n-word what
that really means but you know you have
to tell the very hard stories you have
to make your children very aware of what
goes on in the culture as far as you
know race relations how you might be
perceived as a young black boy and of
course they've watched me do marches you
know they have participated when I took
them to the anniversary for the 100 men
march in Washington DC you know thinks
that you know amongst very powerful
african-american leaders so they are
very much aware of politics they are
very well-spoken on knowing there is a
difference I don't want the
to get in a situation where they think
of fluence
or money will make a difference because
you know if I see you and you're a black
person and I have a preconceived notion
no amount of money will help you in
those moments and we talk about what do
you do with you you know are are
arrested what you do if you're stopped
by a police how do you handle yourself
how do you conduct yourself so that you
make it home alive because that's the
key making it home alive
and you know these videos are non-stop
these stories aren't new to our
community now we just have cameras that
can report them and so you know as you
see you see the whole movement with the
cameras you know you know so every day
there's more
you know footage of people just being
overly how would I describe this
aggressive towards people of color
absolutely you can say racist was
embrace its aggressive against people of
color for no apparent reason but I think
the video of these events have allowed
for people to see the difference and
being a person of color and a white
person because most of us have been a
victim or have experienced some sort of
racism whether it be you know at a
restaurant at a department store you
know in school at your job and you not
tell people in 1998 as a you know lost
to a new lawyer I was the first woman
and person of color to be hired at my
law firm well I mean but my law school
class was only two percent
african-american if if 2 percent I think
it might have been class of 221 maybe 11
people of color and so you know even
though we have made strides there's a
lot of movement that needs to happen for
people of color I was gonna say kind of
on that note of share
entering a law firm experience do you
have a memory of the first time you
experienced racism as a little girl I
really didn't know if I thought racism
really existed until I was hired to do
some tutoring for a white family because
I've always been very intellectually
sound and the young boy said to his
friend sucessful I don't want anyone to
see my tutor because she's black and oh
I cried and I cried because I had never
heard anyone you know and he was
whispering it but I had never heard
anything that sounds so ridiculous
like I don't want someone to see my to
her because she's black and so that was
my first mom away I was like oh my gosh
people really have feelings about people
because they are black and I was just
tutor and I'm like you know why would
that be a problem why would you be
embarrassed by that you know so it yet
was my first you know experience with
you know that I obviously know it is
racist
thank you for sharing that thanks for
being so open and honest always
[Music]